let's go next to eddie from south bend
is that is that south bend indiana
uh yeah that's right can you hear me all
right i can eddie what's going on
so i have possibly your first ever
multiple choice call okay so
on a scale of one to five one being a
super softball question and five being
what many are calling the greatest
indictment of the david backman show
so what would you like on a scale of one
to five
like in other words you have five
different questions that i can choose
from yeah number three is more like i
guess a comment but yeah pretty much
let's not go with that let's go with a
four i'll take a tough question but not
like the toughest
okay so
uh you know i've been going back in your
earlier videos looking at
some of your earlier opinions something
i haven't talked about in a while is
sort of representation and identity
politics okay so to some degree there is
like
i would argue an importance to these
sorts of things and i have a
a story if you wanted from that uh from
an experiment my friend did but in any
case i guess the question would be
uh to what degree would you sacrifice
policy for identity
in politics what do you mean by that i'd
need to what's an example of that can
you give me an example of what it would
mean to sacrifice policy for identity
so let's say uh for instance like the uh
warren versus bernie
right so warren was less good on policy
than bernie
but it would be you know a first woman
presidential candidate
the example i have initially was a
friend of mine did this experiment when
she was a teacher in st louis and this
was during the riots down there she had
all of her students in their fourth
grade class draw a scientist
and every one of them drew a an older
white male okay
and all the students were black and not
one of them drew a black person and they
were wondering why and they were like oh
we don't that's not something i can do
and they they weren't aware of
any black scientists so
to what degree would you be willing to
give in on some policies if any for the
sake of you know giving representation
to unrepresented groups
so um
i mean my view on this really hasn't
changed which is i i care about policy
and
not identity in terms of making
decisions
but i still recognize the importance of
identity
in our understanding of the world and so
my opposition to identity politics has
been
you can't use identity as a cudgel to
silence people
to delegitimize voices and so that's why
i was for example so against when the
women's march said jewish women weren't
intersectional enough to be on the
leadership i was completely against that
i found that vial in my analysis of the
2020 democratic candidates i didn't care
about identity at all i only cared about
policy etc at the same time
um
there is no
understating
the importance and value and inspiration
of for example
we now have a female vice president for
the first time and it's the first you
know there's all these other deca i
don't even know all the category i'm so
out of the identity game that i don't
even know all the all the categories
that kamal harris is part of i think is
is it is there the native american or
asian you know all these different
things okay um there's no question
that for young girls and
young minority girls or all minority
people whatever
um
there's value in seeing
that
there is now an individual that checks
certain boxes that for the first time is
in this role that there's no need to
minimize that what i'm against is using
identity as a cudgel or as a weapon uh
and i don't know if that answers your
question but i think it's a complicated
topic
no i agree it's it's super complicated i
think that's a that's about where i'm at
as well i was kind of curious because in
some of the videos i had seen
it seemed you were very much so like
against identity politics but thanks for
the clarification and like you know yeah
i'm against identity i'm against
identity politics but i'm in favor of
recognizing the value of identity and
what it brings to our conversations of
things
that makes sense
all right my friend thank you very much
for the call i appreciate it
um let's see what else here um
we uh by the way don't don't use my name
on our discord server you're gonna get
banned for that
um so use use a real name don't don't
say your name is david pakman that's not
we don't allow that
let's try zach from orlando zack you're
on the air
zach from orlando you're on the air
hey danny can you hear me just barely
zach go ahead
uh yeah so my question is uh
as someone who considers himself pretty
far left i look at countries like
denmark or norway sweden canada et
cetera as countries that i would like
the united states to kind of emulate
um and i have a lot of conservative
family members i'm like the only one
that's even left i guess okay um and i
never hear them talk about any other
country in a good way i was wondering is
are there countries that the united are
of conservatives uh
praise or think are good
you know i mean you you really have to
ask them but what's really really funny
is that
for these kind of hardcore christian
republicans
the countries that most match their
moral values are radical islamist
countries
that have
you know many of them want a christian
version
of what many of these muslim countries
have
and so it's often what they envision as
ideal is like saudi arabia etc even
though they claim not to like those
countries and it's a very interesting
contrast
but you'd really have to ask them i
don't know what countries they like a
lot of them say they like what
duterte has done and cleaning things up
and whatever you know we're talking
about a dictator here
you'd really have to ask them but
there's some pretty serious hypocrisy
there for sure
of course yeah well thank you very much
for picking on me i didn't think i'd get
called on i appreciate it my pleasure
great to speak to you we're gonna take a
very very quick break if you're holding
to talk to me don't hang up because
we're going to go right back to the
phones momentarily stand by